- Hi, good morning everyone,
and thanks so much for
joining our talk today
on what cloud resilience really means
in the new era we're in today, the AI era.
I'm Dev Rishi, I'm general
manager of AI here at Rubrik,
joined with Adam, the director
of cloud specialists at Rubrik.
Today I'm gonna be spending some time
talking about how Rubrik
thinks about resilience for AI.
Adam is gonna be talking about how Rubrik
protects some of the most
important data aspects
and workloads that are running
in an increasingly cloud native world.
Now at Rubrik, just about a month ago,
we announced a new product
that we're putting out,
and the real orientation for the product
is to underwrite one of the
biggest enterprise trends
that we've observed coming
up over the next 18 months,
and that's really the rise
of agents and agentic AI.
Over the past three months,
I've had a chance to speak
with over 180 different organizations,
at the security and enterprise IT level,
to understand what are some
of their key initiatives
when they're thinking
about their deployments
around AI in 2026 and beyond,
and what are the key concerns
that might be holding them back
from being able to
tackle those initiatives.
Consistently one of the main trends
that arises when it comes
towards the actual application
of AI inside of an organization
is the use of the term agentic.
If you've been walking
around re:Invent this week,
you've probably seen
your fair share of agents
and agentic AI as well.
And I think that it often
helps to be able to start
with a definition for what do we mean
when we talk about agentic AI?
We define agents in agentic AI
as LLMs with access to tools.
What that really means
is models that can take
action on a user's behalf.
It's clear why we think
that this is going to drive
a lot of the enterprise
productivity going forward,
as we think about workflow automation
and productivity gains as
some of the greatest areas
that most enterprises have
for being able to achieve
business transformations.
But the rise of agentic AI
comes with its own risks.
AI agents in many ways are superhuman.
They can operate at a much faster speed
than a normal user might be able to,
but that also means that
they start to operate
at an area where you can do 10x the damage
in 1/10th the time.
Additionally, AI agents operate
with non-human identities and credentials.
They operate within an
enterprise ecosystem
that was not necessarily set
up for the AI generation.
And I think we've started to see
one of the biggest blockers
towards enterprise acceleration
when it comes towards the
deployment of agentic AI
is a fear of risk
or another way, as a lot of IT leaders
I think that I've spoken to have put it,
the lack of understanding
of all the different things
of what could go wrong.
And these aren't hypothetical risks.
We've seen examples of these
already in the early days
of agentic AI.
All the way from moments
in which a chat bot
might be recommending things
like a competitor's product
or even inventing things
via hallucinations
like refund rules,
all the way to more
dangerous types of actions,
like coding agents that have gotten access
to production databases in
order to be able to make change
and affect change, and have
decided to be able to go
and actually do something
to optimize a subroutine
that involves dropping
the production database.
One of the biggest questions
that I think organizations ask
when I speak to them about the
promise of what generative AI
and agentic AI can actually achieve
is how they're supposed to think about
being able to guardrail it
and also what happens in the cases
when things inevitably go wrong.
One of the key aspects by
definition that we think about
with agentic AI is that
it gets your AI agents'
organizations to your
enterprise applications,
tools, and data.
It's really what makes
AI agents unique in terms
of their capabilities.
We're going beyond this ability
to just do knowledge retrieval,
better chats, or search,
and actually going into the world
where an AI agent can update
that opportunity in Salesforce,
help you draft that email in Office 365,
or even be able to help
you update configurations
inside of your AWS account.
But the real trick
that I think a lot of
organizations deal with
is what it looks like to be
able to maintain and manage
this new AI and enterprise
digital workforce
that might be spanning
across different production
applications that were invented
well before the time that these AI agents
actually started to get rolled out.
In speaking with 180 enterprise IT
and security leaders
that I've had a chance
to have conversations with
over the last three months,
here are some of the key sets of concerns
that we've really heard
relatively consistently.
That organizations really tell us
that they lack the single pane of glass
that gives them, starting number one,
an answer to just the simple question
of what AI agents are
even actively running
inside of my ecosystem.
I've spoken to leaders at
Fortune 500 organizations
that talk about how this
is a board-level mandate,
but the way that it's
done today is manual.
There's a committee,
there's a intake process,
or somebody is manually checking
where all these agents are and
creating their own registry.
The next thing leaders are concerned about
is what are the types of tools
and data that an AI agent
can actually access?
Again, oftentimes a
board-level compliance mandate
to be able to make sure that
you have a data use policy
in place, but how does
this actually get enforced
when you have agents that are built in
AWS Bedrock AgentCore, Copilot Studio,
your own custom agents
directly calling open AI,
all the way down to the concern
around how do I actually
recover from an AI mistake?
From my experience, AI agents
have actually never been easier to build.
The long pull in adoption
towards AI acceleration
in organizations is no
longer the difficulty
of being able to use AI.
At this point, building
agents can take days or weeks,
but the deployment process
and the approval process
is actually what I've seen take months.
I spoke with one Fortune 500
leader in financial services
who said that they weren't too worried
about the risks that AI agents might pose
in their organization
because they know it'll
take at least nine months
for that agent to get approved,
and that's not really the formula
for what I think fast
adoption can look like.
We saw this firsthand
even at Rubrik ourselves
as we developed agents at the
beginning part of this year
to be able to start to automate
more and more of our internal workflows.
What we saw was that building
an initial proof of concept
was done quickly.
Our developers, our IT
teams, even business users,
were able to build an
initial proof of concept,
just a prompt and a collection
of like some LLM tools,
within days or weeks.
What it came next though was
really I think the long pull.
You needed to be able
to create design docs
and go through an AI
committee for approval.
The AI committee is
oftentimes cross-functional
across IT, InfoSec, and legal.
By a quick show of hands,
who here works at an organization
that has an AI governance
committee already set up?
About half the room or so.
One of the things that I
think we've consistently seen,
and I sit on our AI
governance committee as well,
one of the things that I consistently see
from an AI governance
standpoint is a real friction
between the people developing AI
and oftentimes the governance
that's supposed to be in place.
One of the things that we experienced
was that each time we needed
to go through this approval,
it would take two months or so,
and that was really before we
started to get into the place
where we were actually ready to build
a production ready agent.
So this entire lens
started to get extended from
the two weeks that we needed
in order to be able to build
that initial proof of concept
to now multiple months to quarters
in order to be able to get
something that is actually,
quote, production ready
and pass these initial
sets of checks.
This was frustrating for us
because each time we had to
go through the review process,
we were essentially
going through a checklist
and trying to make sure
that each of part of what we were doing
was correctly litigated.
Instead, what our developers
and AI agent builders asked
for is define a framework,
define a playground in
a policy environment,
where I can actually go
ahead and build agents
and as long as I'm building
according to the framework
that you've had,
let's cut down on some of
this initial roadblock piece
that allows me to actually
accelerate the pace
at which I'm adopting
and really get to my end goal,
which is an AI agent
deployed in production
as quickly as possible.
To me, the biggest
observation to really entering
into this space is that the real inhibitor
to both ROI and AI, as
well as acceleration AI,
is no longer the difficulty
of using the tooling,
but the risk that comes
with the tooling overall
and the lack of good
and effective frameworks
to be able to tackle that.
That's why Rubrik has decided
to get into this space
and unify some of our core competencies
in data and identity with
this new agentic future.
Now, my name is Dev.
Before I joined Rubrik this
summer via acquisition,
I was co-founder and CEO
of a generative AI
startup called Predibase.
We worked as an LLM infrastructure
platform and the backbone
for a number of leading
technology companies deploying
large language models at scale.
We joined forces with Rubrik this summer
because we see a real opportunity
to be able to take our AI platform
and mix it with what
Rubrik does best in class
across data and identity to
bring the enterprise wave
of AI adoption here sooner.
Rubrik's core has always
been in data backup
and data resilience.
It's a company that
understands data and metadata
incredibly well, providing
data backup services
for some of the world's largest
and most regulated
enterprise organizations.
Rubrik layered on an identity solution
on top of that underlying data layer
to be able to actually target
some of the most compelling
areas where organizations
might see things like cyber attacks
and others that require data resilience.
And with the Predibase acquisition,
we've brought in an LLM and
AI platform that helps us
understand how to be able to
build for an agent feature.
We've combined these
three core competencies
around data, identity,
and an LLM platform for
agents into a single area
that we call our agent
operations platform.
And the key question some
of you might be wondering
is what do I mean by an
agent operations platform?
What does that actually entail?
To us, the agent operations platform,
the product that we've come across with,
we call the Rubrik Agent Cloud.
The Rubrik Agent Cloud is
Rubrik's newest product.
It essentially combines
three key capabilities
that we've heard consistently
from enterprise organizations
they need if they're going
to actually accelerate
the production rollout of AI.
It always starts with
monitoring and observability.
You can't improve systems,
you can't govern systems,
and you can't remediate
systems if you can't see them.
So the first thing the
Rubrik Agent Cloud does
is it hooks into your environment
and automatically discovers AI agents
across the different places
that they may be running
so that we can actually
populate an agent inventory
that shows you what are the
agents that are running,
who's created them,
what are the credentials
that are associated with 'em,
and what are the tools and
data that they have access to.
Earlier this week,
I'm happy to announce we also
announced our integration
with AWS Bedrock AgentCore.
So any agents that you're
natively building within AWS
automatically get discovered
and added inside of our AI
agent inventory as well,
and that provides that
first level of visibility
that many organizations need
when it comes towards AI agents.
The second challenge and the second pillar
for what we think about
we call governance.
Now governance, like AI agents,
can mean a lot of different
things to different people,
but the thing that we've
consistently noticed,
about half the room raised their hand
when I mentioned AI governance committee,
one of the things that
we consistently notice
is that organizations
have governance policies
that are intended to dictate
what AI agents can or cannot do.
For example, AI agents
should not be able to
give financial advice
or mention competitor products,
or AI agents should be operating
in read-only mode by default.
No write agents.
Oftentimes what we see is organizations
have these types of policies,
but no real hooks or teeth
into how to be able to enforce
these policies or even know
that they're being enforced
really at production scale.
Today in most organizations,
this is done on people and paper.
With the Rubrik Agent Cloud,
we're actually translating
this into software.
So policies become configurations
and policies that actually get
defined inside of our system,
either using rule systems
or natural language
and small models, and they can be deployed
for governance in real time
in any of your applications.
And the third and final
pillar of Rubrik Agent Cloud
is something we call remediation.
Rubrik as a company
with its real background
and resilience for the cyber era
has had a quote that
I've liked for a while,
which is called assume breach.
Assume that with all the good
intent that we put in front,
something will eventually go wrong.
And in my experience, I think
that this is more likely
to be true in the agentic future than not.
And so with Rubrik, we've
also released a feature
we call AI Agent Rewind.
What AI Agent Rewind allows you to do
is undo a destructive action
that an AI agent might have taken
on any Rubrik protected property
by allowing you to go ahead
and restore that action
from a previous healthy snapshot
that Rubrik maintains from backup.
So Rubrik is already snapshotting
your production environments
if you're a Rubrik customer
at a frequent cadence that allows us
to be able to offer business resilience.
And what we've done is
we've cross correlated that
with the observability
and governance layer
that we have in the Rubrik Agent Cloud
and allow you to one click rewind
anytime an agent's taken
a destructive action.
So if you think back earlier
to that dropped database example,
the real beauty is you are
no longer stuck in the water
if you actually had an incident like that.
Rubrik's AI Agent Rewind
allows you to remediate quite easily.
These three core pillars
make up what we believe
is one of the real accelerants
towards the adoption
towards AI in a lot of
enterprise organizations,
and I think sets us up
for really the identity that I associate
with Rubrik the most,
which is an organization
that really has evolved
as enterprises have evolved
across different business transformations.
When Rubrik began as a company,
it was really oriented around data backup
for traditional business
continuity and resilience reasons.
Used to be that the biggest threat
that existed out there was
natural disaster, fire, flood.
A number of years later, the
next series of threats came in,
which were cyber disaster, cybersecurity,
ransomware, and others.
Rubrik continued to layer in
by data security and
identity security features
in order to be able to help on this.
And now we're in the AI
enabled disaster era.
And this is where Rubrik
wants to be able to continue its trend
of helping organizations adopt
the next cutting edge
technology by setting them up
for a successful AI adoption cycle.
But as I think we all know,
AI's core is really in
being able to manage
and be able to use your data effectively
for any of the tasks that you're doing.
That's really what makes
generative AI special
inside of each of your organizations.
And in order to be able to
actually have that data,
it relies on the integrity of that data
and the availability of that data,
which is increasingly,
in many organizations,
living more and more in
a cloud-native universe.
And so with that, I wanted to hand it over
to my colleague Adam,
who's gonna be talking
more about what Rubrik
does in the world of cloud
and cloud protection.
- Thanks so much, Dev.
Hey everyone.
Yeah, so I think to piggyback off
of what Dev's talked
about here so far today,
one of the biggest challenges I see,
talking to organizations as
they're moving more and more
of their footprint into cloud
and expanding significantly
is really answering
a fundamental question
of who is responsible
for data resilience?
Now, I think this is a
fairly familiar diagram
to most in the room.
It's a shared responsibility model,
and you know, it states AWS is responsible
for the security of the cloud,
you're responsible for the
security of your data itself.
But this has a push and pull,
I think with a lot of organizations
where there's somewhat of a meta shared
responsibility model.
So when I talk to a lot of organizations
on their data resilience strategy,
depending on which part
of the organization I'm talking to,
what usually ends up happening
when I ask the question
of who's responsible
for your data resilience is
something like this, right?
The platform team
thinks it's security
team's responsibility,
the app dev team
says it's the platform
team's responsibility.
And then both teams are
pointing at security
for anything cyber related
because they're spending a lot of money
on cybersecurity tools,
so they shouldn't have to worry
about remediation in a cyber event.
That's security's job.
This is a big, big challenge,
especially with as disaggregated
as a lot of cloud organizations are
to build efficiency, right?
So there's a lot of
different lines of business
who all have different needs,
and a lot of this also comes
down to taking a step back
and really thinking through
what that mental model
for resilience is and what
you're trying to achieve
with that resilience
for your applications.
There's a traditional high availability
which you get right out of the gate
with a cloud provider like AWS
where you're just trying to
build for that resilience
for common failures.
Operational outages, having, you know,
multi writer, multi
reader nodes in databases.
Things that, you know,
you're designed to build for that failure.
Then there's additionally
disaster recovery,
where you're planning for things like
those natural disasters or
maybe regional outages as well.
Part of that is also cyber resiliency.
So how are you protecting
your data from cyber attacks
and making sure you can
recover effectively?
And these are all things that
organizations need to build
into a continuous improvement,
making sure their CI/CD
pipelines are able to achieve this,
making sure that they have observability
across the board too,
to make sure their
availability is in place.
If there is an outage,
that automation kicks in
to remediate that outage
and really driving towards the ability
to constantly test for
these types of scenarios.
And now, with data resilience,
it's not one size fits all, right?
So every issue you're trying to resolve
has a different mitigating step.
So one of the common ones
most organizations use
is just local snapshots.
So PAZ databases, Dynamo, EC2 Instances,
being able to have snapshots
on those that are local.
So if a Windows update goes bad
or if a database corrupts,
you're able to quickly
roll back those changes
in a couple of minutes.
Something to keep the
application highly resilient
but doesn't meet the
needs for all use cases.
The second one is more for human issues.
So one common occurrence is
not only just accidental issues
that might happen from an automation,
but things like accidental deletions.
And that's where a lot
of times organizations
need to build their
application resilience strategy
to handle for these.
So it's not a matter of just having
a local copy of the data.
If you disable continuous
backups on your Dynamo DB table,
all of your snapshots are gone.
How do you handle for that?
So that's also an area where this is
not only protecting
against that human element,
but also a regional outage too,
and having a copy of your
data in a secondary location.
So then you can do a failover if you need.
Not to be confused with
things like replication
for high availability
use cases and resiliency.
So having an S3 bucket replicating
to another region to
have lower query latency
or things like that,
but really more for that availability
in the event of a disaster.
And then finally,
the thing that a lot of
organizations aren't thinking
of top of mind is how do you recover
in the event of an actual cyber incident?
So in the event of a cyber incident,
that local snapshot you have
is not usable 'cause
there might be malware
on that last snapshot you
took earlier in the day.
So if you restore from that,
you're just reinfecting the environment.
And that's really where organizations
need to have this cyber
resilience strategy
where they have a copy of their backup
in a true cyber-vault
where nobody can touch it,
it's immutable, you can delete it,
and then you can then recover from it
in the event of an incident.
So AWS talks pretty regularly
about this 3-2-1-1-0 principle
for that data resiliency strategy.
Something that I encourage
all organizations to look at,
to think about, if they haven't already.
But what this ultimately
means is you have three unique
copies of your data,
that's not counting the primary copy
that you're using for
production use cases.
Two of those copies,
one will be remote, so you
have it in another region.
And then another one is going to be
that air gap cyber-vaulted copy,
which is kind of your copy of last resort
when you need to recover from
some sort of cyber incident.
And then in addition to that,
you still have that local copy
as well for fast recovery for
those operational instances.
And then the most important
thing is the zero.
Zero issues found on recovery.
And this is one that
a lot of organizations
tend to miss out on
simply because they're not
doing regular recovery testing.
So they're finding zero issues
because they're not doing
the testing in itself.
The last time you wanna,
or the last chance
to find an issue is when
you have an incident
and you can't recover.
You don't wanna find the issue then.
You wanna be able to
proactively find that issue.
Now, I'm not here to say
you should apply this
to every single workload in every single
different application you have
across your cloud environment.
It really also comes
down to this next step
that is pretty often missed
by organizations as well.
And that is really tiering your data
based on its importance.
So if you have a application
that's very, very critical
to the business and minutes of downtime
equates to millions of
dollars lost for the business,
it's a mission critical
application, right?
It needs to be as resilient as possible.
So you need to have that local copy,
you need to have a highly available
or regional copy of that
data to recover from.
And you of course need to have
a fully cyber-vaulted copy as well.
So you're protected from all
different failure scenarios.
Your tier one workloads, still
hugely business critical,
but maybe their downtime impact
is measured more in hours
as opposed to seconds and minutes.
That's where you still
need that local copy,
you still wanna have a remote copy from,
and there is some optionality
as it goes to that cyber resilience.
So sometimes it's workload dependent.
We highly recommend at Rubrik
that this should also
be a cyber-vaulted copy.
It's mission critical.
The downtime for these
types of cyber events
is very, very immense.
So even though it's not that tier zero,
tier one still has a lot of business value
and would create a lot of
business pain in order to recover.
Next is that tier two workloads,
a lot of like internal IT apps
that are probably very, very critical
to the overall business.
You're still gonna wanna
have a local copy of that,
you're still probably going to
want a remote copy for that,
but that is where that cyber-vaulted copy
tends to be a little bit more optional.
I see often with these
organizations, once again,
this is one where we do
recommend a cyber-vaulted copy,
but I see organizations
sometimes combining these.
So they'll have their cyber-vaulted
copy in another region
for these applications.
So it does eliminate one additional copy,
but they're still protected
from both of those use cases.
So they can recover from the
event of a regional outage
with that cyber-vaulted
copy in the other region.
And then last, your tier three workloads,
these are the workloads
that are a lot of the downstream
dev test environments.
Things that are very,
very easily to reproduce.
Maybe it is a bunch of ephemeral
infrastructure as well.
Things that if there's a bad day,
it's not the end of the world.
You can basically repave
the environment, right?
So you can tear down
that whole AWS account
even if there is a cyber attack
and then just redeploy
through something like
infrastructure as code and
a brand new AWS account.
So this is really, really critical
to have a good strategy in place
for classifying and tiering your workloads
to support the resilience
that they require.
One of the other blind spots
and probably the biggest blind
spot I see in organizations
is with S3.
So S3, the data just continues
to grow exponentially
year after year after year.
I'm always excited coming to re:Invent
to hear all about the
new S3 announcements.
S3 tables, vectors.
S3 has, you know, transitioned so much
in such a short period
of time from an archive
and backup use case to really,
it's almost a cloud database.
It's not even just storing
unstructured data anymore.
It's truly storing structured
data with data lakes,
all of the AI related workloads
and ML workloads as well.
And the growth is just massive,
which means there's a
lot of sensitive data
in these S3 buckets,
and there's a lot of potential areas
where not only bad guys can get in,
but even if we're talking about AI agents,
a lot of accidental deletions.
And this means that the lines of business
that are reliant on these S3 buckets
need to know where that sensitive data is
across all these new environments.
They need to know what data
actually needs to get protected as well.
They need to know what does the
recovery scenario look like.
And more importantly, a lot
of these buckets nowadays
are just petabytes and petabytes of data
with billions and billions of objects.
So it also becomes a scaling issue
of just breaking the laws
of physics in some way
of if you have a five petabyte
bucket in billions of files,
how can you recover that
in a timely and effective manner
that isn't weeks to months
of just restoring that data?
And usually when I talk to customers,
they say, I'm not worried about S3
because I have versioning
and replication enabled.
And versioning and
replication just isn't enough
for the types of automation
accidents we see nowadays
and the type of cyber incidents
that we've seen nowadays.
Additionally, because this data
is continuing to grow in these S3 buckets,
there's a lot of additional sensitive data
that ends up in the buckets
that may not be intentionally put there.
So that is all an additional
risk to organizations
because they don't know
where their sensitive data is
in what buckets and that
is a place of exfiltration
for the bad guys.
There is that deletion risk as well
because your latest version
you can recover from
and depending on your
versioning lifecycle policy,
there's a lot of scripting work involved
to try to get that to recover.
And going back to the bucket
that might have billions
of of objects in it,
say a data lake,
just think about the time
taken to try to recover
10% of those objects to
12:00 o'clock yesterday.
Who knows what that looked
like at 12:00 o'clock?
That would be a massive lift.
So it's not a true kind of backup solution
where you can go back to
a point in time easily.
That also leads to some
threat blindness as well
because one common scenario
we tend to see in S3 is there's
a lot of buckets out there
that may have something like a PDF
that external customers download.
So if an attacker can get
access to that bucket,
they can replace that PDF
with a malware version
of that PDF and then that
extends into the environment.
So that might not be
something that's easily found,
but then once it is found,
you need to be able to not only recover
but recover back to the
clean version of that
so you're not reinfecting
your environment.
And that also leads to some
of this recovery uncertainty
with just the fact that these buckets
are growing and growing
and you need to be able to recover quick
so you don't have any elongated downtime
in these large massive S3 environments.
So that's where Rubrik comes in.
I think one of the biggest
things we help customers do,
especially in their AWS estate in general,
but even with S3,
is helping with some
of that data discovery.
Because you don't wanna
slap a backup policy
on every S3 bucket that you
have in your organization.
You just might not need it.
There's a lot of S3 buckets out there
that don't have a lot of
important things in it
that have easily reproducible data
from maybe an Aurora database
that's already being backed up,
but it becomes really,
really hard to figure out
which ones have that sensitive data in it,
might have low hanging
fruit where you do need
that extra level of resilience
in a cyber-vaulted copy.
We also help with that resilience
from protecting against
that deletion risk.
Can actually see, not only,
detect anomalies if there's
a mass deletion event,
one that may be malicious or accidental
in our product by default,
but we also provide
an immutable air gap
copy of that backup data.
So a lot of the bad actors, what they do
when they get into any environment
is to go directly after the backups.
So if the backups aren't
immutable, they can be deleted
and then that means that a ransomware,
I mean it's easier for
that ransomware attack
in the ransom to end up being
in a rock in a hard place
where organizations might
want to end up paying that
'cause they have no other recovery option.
Additionally too, when we take
each one of those backups,
we already are pre-calculating
hashes on all of the backups.
So we can actually see
malware as it comes in,
as it's backed up.
We have thousands of
indicators of compromise
that we're updating daily.
So as we take a backup, we know instream
of that backup if there may
be some sort of bad actor
involved in there and any sort of malware.
Part of that too is
helping us detect zero days
because as a zero day, so we
might have been backing up
that bad file weeks ago,
and that impacts a lot of the recovery.
So whenever we see something
bad in the environment,
we'll auto quarantine it
so you're not reinfecting the environment
in a matter of a restore.
But additionally we're
taking all of these different
threat feeds and then we
have the ability to scan
all of the backups we've ever taken
and see if that zero day has impacted
other parts of the environment.
So you might have a security tool pop
and say, hey, there's
an issue in account one
and it might have already had an issue
in account three, four, and five
that the security tools
haven't picked up on yet.
So we can help across the board recover
to that clean point in time
in a manner of minutes.
And what we do across our platform
with Rubrik is really tie this together
in one single platform.
So, from the ground up,
and I'll talk about our
architecture here more momentarily,
it is very cloud native
focused architecture.
So all the different AWS
workloads you see on the left,
we protect under what we
call Rubrik Security Cloud,
which is our overall SaaS platform.
It helps with agentic AI,
it helps with automation.
We have full automation AAPI
capabilities on top of it.
We're protecting data and identity.
And then we're doing data protection,
not only of cloud resources,
data center resources,
we also protect identity.
So if you think about it,
if your identity's
compromised Okta, Entra ID,
in the event of a cyber attack,
you can't even log into anything.
So that's often one of the
areas where we're protecting.
So you can do quick recovery of that
before you move into the
traditional production workloads.
As part of all that too,
we help customers identify
the sensitive data
in their environment,
through data discovery and classification,
that makes sure they're backing
up the critical workloads
in the environment and
not having any blind spots
in their overall data resiliency strategy.
And then on top of that, as I mentioned,
we're doing anomaly detection
and threat monitoring
and turbo threat hunting on
all backups that we take.
So that's all on by default
and not something that you
have to regularly manage.
So that's all in one platform.
And then in addition to that
we have third party integrations
with a lot of other
cybersecurity companies out there
to really bring that all under
one umbrella in one platform.
Now, as I talked about earlier too,
with classifying that tiers of data,
one of the coolest things
I like about our product
is a functionality we have,
we call it cloud posture risk management.
So before you take a
single backup with Rubrik,
you can plug in all of your AWS accounts
and we'll immediately
give you feedback on,
say you have 800 cloud
objects, you know, EC2,
S3 buckets, whatever they may be,
we'll tell you which ones
you're currently backing up
with snapshots today.
Additionally, on top of that
we can get a sense of if
there's any sensitive data
in any of these cloud objects.
So if you have 800
objects, maybe 500 of them
are protected with snapshots today,
and the remainder though, the other 300,
maybe those are test dev workloads,
maybe those are things
that just are blind spots
and you're not protecting today,
we can see maybe there's 100
of them that we have found
some indicators that there's
sensitive data in there,
and that's a way for
these lines of business
to quickly realize, okay,
maybe there's sensitive data
in a downstream dev environment
that shouldn't be there and
let me delete that altogether.
Or maybe this was a science experiment
that quickly turned into
a production application
that now is running customer data,
and we don't even have
snapshots in place on that.
So we're not even doing the basics
of local recovery, let alone cyber
or disaster recovery to plan for.
So, something very quickly in these large
sprawling environments
to try to, you know,
have a good starting point
of finding those blind spots
in the overall cloud estate.
Now talking about how we're built
from an architectural standpoint.
So we do everything with
a lot of automation.
Especially when I'm
talking to AWS customers,
they wanna do everything automatically.
So we make that very, very
easy for our customers.
So you have Rubrik Security Cloud
that is that SaaS platform,
that one platform that everybody logs into
to manage everything,
from M365 to data center
to cloud to AI agents.
For AWS we have a dedicated AWS account
for each one of our customers under that.
And then everything in pink here
is customer managed environment.
So to do our install, this
can all be done via Terraform.
We also support cloud formation
and just native APIs as well.
We will deploy a cross account IAM role.
Now these roles are least privileged,
and we also support role chaining.
So since we're doing a
cross account IAM role
to perform backup and restore operations,
that role chaining allows organizations,
if there is some sort of incident
and you wanna quickly
cut off access to Rubrik
for some reason,
you can just impact that
one cross account role
that is chained
and then that will eliminate all access
to the other hundreds of accounts
you may have connected to Rubrik.
And then each one of these
other cross account roles
over on the left here,
they're fully leased permissive model.
So in that top box there
we have EC2, RDS, and S3,
but there's no Dynamo DB.
So you can have that IAM
role say Rubrik has no access
to any Dynamos, we have
no Dynamo ever planned
in that environment,
making sure that we are just adhering
to that least principle.
Over on the right there's
two special accounts.
So first we have a restricted
data processing account.
This is where we're doing
all of our data processing
for backups.
We want that to be restricted,
we want that to be very minimal access.
We don't want other
applications running in there
because this is doing all
of the the heavy lifting.
So we wanna make sure there
is nobody with physical access
to that to interrupt backup
and restore operations.
The way we're actually
processing all of this data
is through something we call Exocompute.
So that uses Kubernetes under the cover.
So stateless workload.
When we're not performing
backup and restore operations,
it's a footprint of zero
in your cloud environment.
But when we are performing
backup operations,
this means we can scale
very linearly as well.
So if you have one thing to
back up, we have one pod.
If you have 1,000 things
that need to be backed up,
we'll spin up 1,000 pods.
So very, very efficient as we scale
to meet large cloud environment needs.
And then that, below that,
is what we call our data bunker account.
So this is gonna be
another restricted account
and this is gonna be where we
would store the backup data.
So it'll be in an immutable S3 bucket.
One of the other things
we're able to do here as well
is tier off the different storage classes.
So instead of having everything in an S3
standard storage class,
you can tier that down
to infrequently accessed
or even glacier depending on the use case.
So this is an immutable environment
where nobody has access to it.
So if there is a malicious attack,
your backups cannot be
impacted whatsoever,
and you'll always have a
clean point to recover from.
We do also offer what we
call Rubrik Cloud Vault.
So this is a logically
air gapped environment.
It looks very, very similar
except that the S3 bucket is
in a Rubrik owned AWS account.
So that means it's in
a completely separate
security domain altogether
from your primary environment.
Now, how do we automate from here
after that initial setup, and
that is through tag-based.
So, going back to that
classification we talked about
earlier in the tiering,
a lot of organizations
will have what we call SLAs,
which are backup policies.
So gold, silver, bronze,
just for simplicity
for developers adhering to this.
Gold may be a copy goes to another region
and you also have a cyber-vaulted copy.
Silver is just a remote region one.
And then maybe bronze
is just that local copy
for fast recovery.
So as application developers
build their infrastructure,
the platform teams that they help support,
they can just tell their developers,
this is mission critical,
this is tier one or tier zero.
Make sure you put, you know,
backup equals gold as a tag
on that environment and
we'll automatically start
backing that up.
So the application team
don't have to get involved
too heavily in managing
their own backup and restore
if they don't want to.
They can offload a lot
of that mental burden.
But everybody still knows,
in the organization,
what is backed up, what is not backed up,
what is protected and at what level.
This goes to the next step as well
where as new accounts get
onboarded into the environment,
we can place that cross account IAM role
as part of a deployment pipeline.
And then any new resources
created in that new AWS account,
assuming that they are tagged properly,
will automatically start backing it up.
We do also have automated
role-based access control.
So if you do have an app team
that does wanna self-service
their backup and restore,
you can limit their access in the Rubrik
security cloud environment
so they can only see the AWS accounts
that hold the data they care about
and not the entire enterprise.
With all of this as well,
this is also how we can integrate
from infrastructure as code
standpoint for recovery.
So if you need to recover
to a net new environment,
you simply would deploy that
code pipeline, new AWS account,
our cross account IAM role is in there,
and then you can instantly
start recovering.
Now, I talked a lot about Terraform,
infrastructure as code,
and I think that leads to one
of the next big blind spots
I've seen over the past
probably 12 months.
Automation is kicking off
more and more across the environment.
Developers are developing more and more.
And one of the next biggest gaps
is the DevOps environment itself, right?
There is a lot of news
in this space recently
with the overall DevOps platforms,
where that code repository is,
and these are really critical
workloads for organizations.
Not only is it where the
crown jewels of code lives,
the metadata around all of that code,
and then also a lot of
the collaboration tools
and protectivity tools that
these app teams leverage.
So, it is the work
items, the wikis, right?
The IAC pipelines, the ML pipelines,
those are all included
in these DevOps workloads
and things like GitHub, GitLab, et cetera.
And if you start thinking through this
a little bit more and more,
this becomes a pretty key area of downtime
if there are any issues
in this environment
as it impacts each one
of these areas here.
So from that developer
collaboration standpoint
with things like wikis and work items,
well if there's an issue
in that part of the
environment, guess what?
Engineering planning comes to a halt.
There's no more PRD reviews.
What is the next thing I
need to do for this project?
You know, until that's recovered,
they're dead in the water.
If you're pushing out a new update,
maybe there's a large marketing event
and you're planning on pushing an update,
well if your CI/CD pipelines are down,
you can't push that out.
Or maybe there's a critical
bug that needs to get fixed.
Your AI ML pipelines too.
When those models are paused
'cause there's issues,
that means there's a lot of
potentially expensive GPUs
going to waste during that time period.
And then going back to what we
talked about originally here,
that cloud info management.
So your infrastructure as code.
Well if you have a cyber incident,
how can you repave that
environment and redeploy
if you can't access your
infrastructure as code state files?
So that's why, as a result of
this too, or apologies too.
So the way that is typically
protected today as well
tends to also fall down.
So there is native version history, right?
So a lot of time with some
of these native tools,
you have about a 30 day recovery window,
a little bit of a recycling bin,
but that's limited retention.
And then there is that
vulnerability to permanent loss,
'cause you can empty the recycling bin
and then there goes the data.
So that leads to a resilience gap.
There's also a lot of
manual scripting you can do
to do your own form of
backup for a lot of these.
That creates a lot of operational overhead
and who's monitoring all of these scripts?
So that means that I've
seen time and time again
where organizations thought the process
was working but the script
needed an update that never got updated.
The monitoring wasn't in place,
so they thought things
were being backed up
and they didn't realize it
wasn't until there was an issue.
And then there's the other option of,
hey, I also, my developer,
I have my code also sitting
on my laptop as well, right?
So hey, the code repository goes away,
I have a copy of it on my laptop.
We'll just recover from that.
Not only is that a governance nightmare
for many InfoSec teams,
there's also a recovery gap.
Whose laptop is the code on?
What version of code do they have?
How am I gonna recover that back
for all my other developers?
And then lastly, there's
a lot of point solutions
out there as well to handle some of this.
But part of the issue with point solutions
is that's just another
tool in the environment
of ever-growing tools,
which means oftentimes too there
tends to be compliance gaps
where these point solutions
aren't meeting the needs
of a more enterprise organization
from a compliance standpoint.
So recently we just announced
our own DevOps protection.
So we're able to protect
these code repositories,
all of these pipelines,
and ensure that in the event of an outage
you can recover these
so then you can recover
your cloud infrastructure
as part of it as well.
It helps with the automation,
it helps with ensuring that resiliency.
And most importantly too,
this is all integrated
into that general Rubrik security cloud
so you're not managing multiple tools.
It's all together in one single platform.
So with that, I did wanna give everybody
in the room some homework.
So, 'cause who doesn't
love a little homework?
So when you go back to
meet with your teams,
and I know often there's the team meeting
after a re:Invent of hey, what
did you learn at re:Invent?
So I think some things you can
pose to your internal teams
to get some of the gears going too
is do you really have a clear strategy
to govern and protect against
destructive AI agent actions
that Dev talked about?
Additionally too, has the
organization defined a Cyber RTO?
So RTO, recovery time objective,
that's something that's been
around for a long time, right?
If the business can sustain
four hours of downtime,
you need to restore that
application within four hours.
Cyber RTOs really translate over
to if there is a malicious
attacker in our enterprise,
what is the recovery time
from that ransomware attack?
Most organizations don't have this defined
'cause they've never tested it,
but when you ask anybody, they usually go,
it's gonna be a long time.
And the impact to a lot of
the recent ransomware attacks
and cyber attacks we've seen
that have had elongated downtime,
it's not because they didn't
have backups in place.
It's that they couldn't find
a clean point of recovery
to restore from.
So they're getting in
this repetitive motion of,
let me restore from the latest snapshot,
go run a bunch of security tools on it
to make sure it's clean.
If it's not, rinse and
repeat that process.
If you do that across
thousands of cloud objects,
that becomes a massive lift
and elongates downtime significantly.
And then additionally too,
how are you safeguarding
that DevOps environment?
It's now a tier zero application.
I walked through all
the potential scenarios
that can cause massive compliance issues
and resiliency issues in
the development life cycle.
So how is that being handled
today if there is downtime?
And then lastly and
still one of the things
that I think is most important,
when was the last time
you've actually ran a test?
Can you recover if there is an outage,
be it cyber, be it
regional, be it operational,
is there actually a true way to recover?
So with that, thank you
all. Here's the QR code.
I think we have a little
bit of time for Q&A too.
All right, well we'll be hanging around
if there's any other questions after this,
but thank you all.
- [Dev] Thank you all very much.